today we invited the seven speakers
from the nih brain initiative cell
census network
biccn to present their recent
work using scalable single cell
approaches
through catalyzing brain cell diversity
their research is a major effort of the
biccn
founded about two and a half years ago
the overarching goals are to generate
comprehensive
as well as highly granular reference
brain analysis
that will integrate molecular anatomical
and functional features of brain cells
and to develop new tools for
experimental access
to the different cell types in alignment
with the number one
priority of the brain initiative as
recommended
in brain 2025 report
this symposium entitled molecular
taxonomies of brain cells will showcase
several biccn projects from
identifying brain cell diversity
establishing brain cell taxonomies to
developing new cell type specific
targeting tools in a manner not
requiring germline genome modification
the symposium will present first a
comprehensive
single cell transcriptomic survey and
identification of new cell types in
mouse cellular pattern
by evan mccaskill
second cross-species evolutionary study
of
brain cell types in marmoset human
mouse and other species by hannah quinan
and schreif falcon third comprehensive
epigenomics characterization of brain
cell types
by sebastian crystal and zhu zhu zhang
those data integration and cross
validation by iran mukamel
and the last single cell multi-omics
analysis
and the new viral tools targeting brain
cell types by brazil got pasic
now without further ado let me introduce
our first speaker
evan mccoskell from broad institute
he's going to talk about his title is a
transcriptomic attack of the mouse
cerebellum
reveals regional specialization of the
novel cell types
thank you very much yang
as yong mentioned i will be telling you
today about a comprehensive cell atlas
of the mouse cerebellum
which is part of a larger atlas that we
are constructing using droplet-based
single nucleus rna-seq
across the entire mouse brain and this
is the first portion
of the data set that has been completed
and analyzed
the data set was constructed by taking a
total of six
uh mice for male to female
separately dissecting each lobule of the
cerebellum
processing it through a newly optimized
form of single nucleus rna-seq which
yields very high numbers of genes per
profile to yield a total of 800 000
profiles across
all of these individual 16 lobular
regions
we then performed liger an analysis tool
that we developed
previously and a total of six hundred
and eleven thousand quality controlled
profiles
distributed across both glial and
neuronal types
here is a uh image of the uh the
the overall dendrogram of relationships
amongst those 46 clusters we identified
on the top
are glial clusters which were largely uh
shared
with other brain regions except for the
very unique birdman
cells and then on the bottom are a
series of neuronal types that we
identified that are quite specific to
the cerebellum
using the allen brain atlas we were able
to annotate the locations and the
uh the identities from previous work of
the major
uh neuronal classes the purkinje cells
granular cells and then
golgi interneurons in a variety of other
interneurons
we use this data set to answer two big
questions in the cerebellum
the first big question was how much
regional variation is there
across individual cell types
and this arises from a larger question
that's been in the field for a while in
the cerebellum
which is how much to what extent are the
circuits of the cerebellum which is a
very
large structure the same across all
these lobules versus different
the canonical view is that they're
relatively uniform
that that input comes through
the climbing fibers and that output is
through the purkinje cell so the
the the large-scale circuit is is sort
of thought to be the same across the
individual lobules
but there are some hints of of alternate
ideas of this and the most
uh commonly cited one is the zebra
pattern of expression in the purkinje
cells that there are certain genes that
seem to be
uh longitudinally expressed across uh
these
zebra looking stripes in the cerebellar
structure
indeed when we looked at our purkinje
profiles we found that there was
aldoc positive and negative subclusters
within our purkinje analysis
and that there was a much greater
specialization amongst the purkinje
clusters
that were aldo positive than aldoc
negative um
and furthermore that the aldoc uh uh
the populations that we identify these
nine different purkinje populations
seem to be particularly regionally
enriched in posterior lobules suggesting
that the posterior lobules
are considerably more diverse in their
cell specializations than the anterior
lobules
another big question that we had of
course whenever you're doing one of
these large scale surveys of a tissue
is are there any new cell types that we
didn't know about already
and uh indeed there was a population
that seemed uh
unique to us and and one that was hard
for us to annotate and they were in the
molecular layer
uh of the of the cerebellum now in the
molecular layer
it's been known that there is a
continuum
of morphologies that exist from the um
outer third
where stella morphology cells exist and
then the inner third
where these basket cells exist and these
uh morphologies were initially
identified by kahal
uh more than a hundred years ago in our
taxonomy
we identified two populations which we
call mli1 and mli2
which localized to um the um
the molecular layer we did initially
confirmed this using our technology
slide seek
um but we also confirmed it as i'll show
in a minute with single molecule fish
and the mli1 and mli2's are quite
distinct they have many many different
markers
that separate them and in fact the mli2s
look more like purkinje layer
interneurons than molecular layer
interneurons
and here is a fish image to show you
that there is this
two pair of populations separated by
these genes source iii and
nxph1 both present in the molecular
layer
about a two to one ratio of these two
populations
we were curious to know what these
populations actually did in the
cerebellum
so we developed a pipeline so that we
could jointly molecularly phenotype
physiologically phenotype and
morphologically phenotype these cells
the way we did it is we patch cells in
acute slices
we filled the cells with an alexa dye
and then we did post
hoc hcr single molecule fish to identify
which of these two mli populations there
were
the long and the short of it is that the
two populations both
show a continuum of basket and steli
morphologies which is very surprising to
us the same
continuum from the distal part on the
top
where both mli ones and mli2's look
stellate like
to the inner portion of the layer where
they both looked
more basket-like
but nonetheless they had very very
distinct physiologies they were
different in their firing rates in their
excitabilities
and then uh most strikingly um which
i'll end with
is um they they actually have
differential uh gap junctioning
properties and this was first
hypothesized from our data
because only one population the mli1
population
expresses the canonical gap junction
gene connects in 36
which we confirmed by single molecule
fish is extremely unique to mli ones
compared to mli twos
and then our collaborators in wade
revere's lab recorded from individual
cells using a technique that allows them
to
identify electrical coupling these spike
lit recordings
and they found only spikelets to be
present in the mli ones
and not in the mli twos
so in conclusion um we've identified
we've constructed a data set that
provides a community resource to
basically identify all the molecular
phenotypes of cell types within the
cerebellum at lobular resolution so we
can see
the differences across each individual
region we see more molecular diversity
in the posterior lobules this is
exemplified by the purkinje cells but
it's also the case
for the granular cells and the other
cell types where we also saw some
regional specialization
and we also identified a new cell type
um that's extremely distinct from the
molecular layer uh
two sort of populations in within the
molecular layer that are quite distinct
um despite the fact that they have
nearly um indecipherable uh morphologies
um across the the tissue layer
so with that um i would like to just
thank our collaborators uh in the raid
reviewers lab and also in aviva gev's
lab
and also recognize the uh folks who led
this work especially velena kozareva
and carly martin thank you very much but
now i'd like to introduce fena crenin
from harvard medical school
hi everyone thanks evan for the
introduction thanks to the organizers
and to young for moderating this
fascinating
session so i wanted to share some of the
work
that was really enabled by our
participation in the biccn
so we've been generating a single cell
molecular and cellular atlas of the
marmoset brain
and one of the first things we wanted to
ask or evaluate
and that you might wonder is what really
does a primate by you in terms of
conservation
of the cell types and molecular programs
that we might see
in humans and so to to initiate these
kinds of questions we took a comparative
approach
and we really focused on interneurons in
particular
in part because um previous work
uh looking at molecular taxonomies of
cell types has
has emphasized and is true at the
broadest level they
are quite conserved relative to other
neuronal types all the way from reptiles
to humans
um and also because we and others have
seen that the molecular profiles of
specific
subtypes or subtypes of interneurons
at least in the neocortex of mice tend
to be quite stable across
areas and so literally interneurons made
a quite a conservative but then
potentially informative place to start
these kinds of comparative
questions and we acquired data from
three primates from humans macaques and
marmosets as well as from mice and
ferrets
sampling multiple neocortical regions
the striatum hippocampus
and of these larger data sets we carried
forward about
000 interneurons for our analyses
and when we began this um this project
we
started with really a simple list of the
ways we might expect brain cell types to
evolve
actually we only thought of three of
these but but found a fourth in the
in the process of this work so we
thought you can change the abundance of
the conserved type across species you
might change the genetic program or
molecular details of the conserved types
you could allocate the same type
differently across brain structures or
contexts
and then potentially you might also
invent a novel type
so to the first point consistent with
stereology we found that interneurons
as a percentage of all neurons in
sensory cortical areas like v1
made up about 13 12 and a half 13 to 20
percent of all
neurons and that's quite consistent with
the literature
and it's also quite stable across
species
primates though allocate a far greater
proportion of the interneurons to the
higher order association areas like
prefrontal cortex but also higher order
areas in parietal and temporal lobes
and relative to mice who tend to have
more uniform distribution
what we didn't expect is that the
ferrets actually allocate
interneurons in proportions that
resemble primates much more
than they do mice and so in this regard
and contrary to what you might predict
by evolutionary divergences of these
species
the mice appear to be the outlier
um we can also of course examine
relative proportions of subtypes of
interneurons such as those arising from
different embryonic origins
and this all again reinforces to us that
primase
primates seem to customize the
allocation of these major types
within different neocortical area areas
and that might contribute to new
cortical specialization
and again this is a this is important
for us to see that a marmoset even
though
it has a small and smooth neocortex and
diverged from us over 45 million years
ago
seems to allocate interneurons in these
basic proportions in very similar ways
to humans
and turning to another way that cell
types might evolve we found that
neocortical neurons in all five species
could be partitioned into four main
categories
um and and they can be nicely marked by
canonical markers like private humans
and statin and so forth
and we could then examine the relative
expression levels of other genes
within those main conserved classes and
this
plot on the right really illustrates one
of the main patterns which is um
that energy expression with one such
gene that has quantitative variation
amongst interneuron types energy
expression levels in humans can be quite
nicely predicted by the relative levels
of the gene in marmoset or mechanic
interneurons
but not so much so by the levels in the
non-timing
and so we can summarize this behavior
broadly across hundreds of genes that
are
expressed in all five species within
interneurons
in cortex and show that evolution really
constrains the quantitative expression
levels of genes even if they
are panronal that is not marker or genes
for any particular population um i want
to briefly foray into another
facet of this idea of changing the
molecular composition of conserved types
um because remember i told you that both
we and others have observed but
interneurons in mice really don't vary
that much by cortical area relative at
least to excitatory neurons
um of a given flavor of internal lettuce
but our because we had collected so many
neocortical regions in the marmoset we
could
ask this question in a primate context
and it turns out that
the same subtype of interneurons say a
parvalbumin subtype
sampled across multiple cortical regions
do
does have quite a lot of variation in
gene expression and this variation
seems to follow an unexpected spatial
logic
that is if you line up the cortical
areas from the anterior lobe
anterior pole to the posterior pole you
can find dozens
if not hundreds of genes who express
whose expression level correlates with
that spatial
arrangement we were able to validate we
validated some of these with single
molecule fish such as here where you see
the gene ass1
and purple is more expressed within
parallel beam and interneuron types
in the frontal portions of the marmoset
neocortex
relative to the probability of
interneurons in the back and this could
be quantified from the single molecule
fish images
so it turns out that um interneurons may
retain their spatial positioning
information within the quantitative
deployment of many genes
and what's interesting is that these
same genes actually exhibit the same
regional bias
within the other species as well of
course the magnitude and the percent of
agreement is higher within the primates
but even the non-primates seem to to
follow this
kind of spatial logic as a trend is
there for all of them supporting this
idea that
maybe interneurons encode some aspect of
the regional
position within the neocortex
uh turning to the third possibility so
just briefly we observe this
really what is a special case of
modifying abundances
and that is that there's an interneuron
subtype that is abundant in the mouse
hippocampus um also in ferret but has
become
rather abundant in the neocortex of
primates as well
and this of course raises really
interesting developmental questions
about how interneurons get allocated
across structures
um and i should mention that gord
fischel who is a collaborator on this
project had this initial insight of
looking across
structures to unify molecular types
and then finally um what we expected
that if anything
if we're going to observe a novel type
that it would be in the neocortex of the
primates
um actually we were surprised to find a
novel type
in uh rather in the marmoset striatum
that we didn't observe in mouse
and this is a type that expressed an
unique suite of
neuropeptides like tac-3 and vip but
also transcription factors like lhx-6
suggesting
but it may have an mge origin like most
of the striatal interneurons
um in and
what was interesting though is that
these this type we could also
observe in humans but not in ferret
suggesting that
it might be an evolutionary gain after
the primate rodent
split so with that i just want to
close thanking my collaborators and just
suggesting that i i think we'll find we
and others will continue to find many
more such examples
of of evolutionary novelties and
conservation and divergence
as we sub survey more regions and
species
um and that is the perfect uh segway to
introduce trigs triglebakken from the
allen
allen institute who will be discussing
um
work on evolution of cellular diversity
and motor cortex
of human marmoset and mass thanks
thanks fenna and thanks yang for
organizing this session
um today i'd like to tell you about work
that was
really done in collaboration with many
of the biccn teams
and this was to look at a functionally
conserved area
primary motor cortex across primarily
three species
human marmoset and mouse with a small
subset looking at macaque layer 5.
and this collaboration extended both to
the data generation and on the analysis
side
and acknowledging some of the groups on
the right there involved
the different modalities that we were
profiling
cellular diversity in this area included
two rna-seq assays
one for full-length transcripts
smartseek and
a droplet-based method from 10x genomics
dna methylation and open chromatin
either alone or in conjunction with rna
from the same nuclei
so these assays were all profiling a
single nuclei in order to increase our
ability to compare across species
and i'm showing on the bottom an example
of dissociating these nuclei from
postmortem human tissue where we're able
to identify
in coronal slabs the region of interest
based on gyro folding patterns confirmed
based on the histology particularly
these large
pyramidal neurons in layer 5 called bet
cells
and then dissociated single nuclei and
enriched for neurons
by sorting for nu n and then profiled
with multi-omics
methods listed above and
then performed unsupervised clustering
on each individual
modality so this
this effort resulted in approximately
100 cell types identified in each of the
species that have been
arranged in taxonomies on the left
and are really the highest resolution
taxonomy came from
the droplet-based rna-seq method and
that's what's shown here
we could then leverage shared
coexpression across these species to
integrate
nuclei into a common space
and then perform unsupervised clustering
in that space
to define a final set of 45 consensus
types
that were shared across these species
there were a couple of types that were
unique to species that i won't
address here but just to say that there
are some
for example progenitor populations of
glial cells that are
more found in mouse than in primate but
these consensus types
involve included a number of types that
match one to one across species
including chandelier cells
although of note there is a very rare
subtype of mouse
chandelier cell that that we didn't see
in the primates
but then some many to many matches such
as basket cells
we also of course had the epigenetic
information for these
different species and what we found is
that the gene regulatory signatures were
highly consistent with expression
so here i'm showing on the left an
integration
of human glutamatergic neurons profiled
with rna and dna methylation
and have been integrated into this space
based on
hypomethylation of gene bodies and
marker gene expression
and then and so an unsupervised
clustering
independent of the rna clustering in
with using the dna methylation data
could then be mapped back to the rna
clusters based on correlated marker
expression
and we found many again many one-to-one
matches
and also some one of many matches
likely due to less sampling of nuclei in
in the dna methylation data set
so with this epigenetic we could also do
a similar process for the open chromatin
where we also found very
good alignment and then with this
epigenetic data in hand
we could ask questions such as are there
conserved transcription factor binding
site motifs
across species and this is in fact what
we found
so i'm showing example here for lamp
five
interneons a subclass of interneurons
where
each row on the on the left is uh
shows enrichment for different
transcription factors
both in the hypomethylated regions and
open chromatin
for this subclass and corresponding rna
expression for that transcription factor
and these were were quite quite
conserved across the species
but the stinks between subclasses shown
on the right
so this is a tsne showing in colors the
different
excitatory and inhibitory subclasses
and in different shapes of point are the
different species
we could also ask questions like
to try to relate conserved cellular
properties to conserve molecular
properties
so chandelier cells have been well
described in a number of species
and share common distinct features
relative to other fast spiking inner
neurons the basket cells
in inhuman and non-human primate and
mouth shown on the top
and likewise we could find a set of 25
marker genes that discriminate
chandelier cells from basket cells and
were shared across the species
and these genes included three
transcription factors
including this gene ror a which
in a similar analysis to what i showed
previously
we showed significant enrichment in
chandelier cells
compared to basket cells the motif
binding site for that
for that transcription factor both based
on the dna hypomethylation and the open
chromatin
finally i know in addition to many
conserved genes
as fenna mentioned there are many
genes with differential expression
across species for
homologous types so here i'm showing uh
just the gabaergic neurons in a
two-dimensional projection of the
integrated space
a umap projection where the colors
indicate the species are well intermixed
and the different colored islands
correspond to the major subclasses of
gabaergic
neurons and we can identify on on the
order of one to two hundred
markers within each species for for each
of these subclasses
including parbobumin positive
interneurons
but only a small subset of those are are
shared across all three species
with more sharing between primates than
with mouse
and that's indicated both by this venn
diagram and also on the right for each
of the subclasses showing
a limited set of conserved markers and
many species specific markers
so what i think i've shown is that there
are a conserved
set of types that have conserved for at
least 65 million years
and therefore likely point to a
functional significance of those types
there's putative developmental
mechanisms for cell type identity
suggested by this conserved
transcription factor code
and there is evidence for specialization
of types across species
based on divergent marker expression
so with that i'd like to thank not only
are all the bsccn collaborators who
contributed to this work but the very
various teams that contributed from the
allen institute
and of course i'd like to thank our
founder paul allen for his
vision and support and i'd like to
introduce our next speaker sebastian
pricel from uc san diego
thank you trucker and thank you very
much to the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to talk
today about our study on things like
chromatin accessibility landscapes of
mouse brain cell
types and the overarching question that
we're trying to ask is what are the gene
regulatory programs
and genomic elements that are underlying
the unique identity
and function of brain cell types and
we're really trying to understand
the diverse molecular cell types
identified by high throughput single
cell
rna-seq analysis and spatial
transcriptomics
how the cell has specific gene
expression patterns
established and how are they encoded in
the genome and therefore we are striving
to
map the cis regulatory elements in short
cres
in the mouse genome in brain cell types
and these cis regulatory elements which
can be separated into
enhancers and promoter elements are
characterized by
and can be identified by open chromatin
which can be targeted by
the method ataxic and in order to
profile open chromatin regions in
specific steps in the brain we implied a
highly scalable single color taxi method
which uses a combinatorial bow coding
split pool approach where we in the
first step perform fragmentation in 96
well plates with the well specific
barcode
pull all nuclei together and separate
them into a second set of 96 well plates
with the indexed
pcr using this highly highly scalable
approach we were able to
generate a single nucleus the taxi
profiles for more than 800
nuclei from 45 that affects the brain
regions which were dissected from
coronal
sections along the anterior posterior
axis of the mouse brain
and were part of the four main regions
the isocortex the olfactory bulb
the hippocampus and cerebral nuclei
which comprise striatum and pallidum
using this uh eight hundred thousand
nuclei dr young liam being rent lab
performed iterative clustering to
identify
um not only the cell classes non-neurons
gaba orgy and prosthetic metallurgic
neuron but also 43
major neuronal types and could further
subdivide them into 160
subtypes for our cluster annotation we
used um
chromatin accessibility at promoter and
gene body regions of
canonical marker genes and could see
that for example in the major types
we found the one d2 medium spiny neurons
hippocampal
granular cells and several layer
specific cortical glutamatergic neurons
we could then using the single cell
ataxic data we could further subdivide
these major types
into into subtypes and for example i'm
showing you here
for the ssp inhibitory neuron subclass
we actually identified 10
subtypes and one of these represent the
lung projecting
gabaergic neurons indicated by
accessibility as the chondrolactin
locus we next ask how does this
molecular taxonomy from chromatin
accelerability compare to
taxonomy defined by single cell
transcriptomes and for that
we integrated our single cellular tactic
data with uh things that rna speak data
from standard innocence group
for uh matched brain regions and could
identify that
for 160 singapore taxi clusters we found
a match
in the singapore rna-seq um
taxonomy which indicates that there's a
well correspondence between both
taxonomies and
motivated by that we were wondering can
we now
go to the next step to identify specific
regulators of this g
that's delta specific gene expression
and here i'm showing you our strategy to
identify putative enhancers for
celta targeting first we
identified these elements these distal
elements out of our catalog of 490
000 elements which are co-accessible
with promoter regions
which indicates that they might likely
regulate this gene or could could
regulate this gene
and in the second step we performed
pearson correlation between
accessibility at this distal
cis regulatory element and rna
expression in the joint clusters
using this approach we were able to
identify 130 000
positively correlated pairs which
comprised
80 it's roughly 86 000 putative
enhancers which were linked to
10 000 genes that were expressed in the
in
in the brain cell types so on average we
identified seven enhancers for any given
gene promoter
and the average distance between uh
enhancer and sheen was around 180
megabases next we were wondering if
using this comprehensive list of
positive enhancers if we could get
insight in what are the
enhancers in specific cell types and to
do that
we grouped the enhancers into modules
based on
accessibility across the joint clusters
and could identify 38 modules with one
on top the module which was broadly
accessible across all neuronal cell
types
and all the other modules all the other
37 modules showed a more
cell type restricted accessibility
notably this
accessibility was highly correlated with
and highly mirrored the
target gene expression and notably we
didn't see
such high variation in accessibility at
the promoter regions which
further highlights the notion that
enhancer regions really
drive cell type specific gene expression
patterns
and we sort of wanted to know what are
the transcriptional regulators
driving this accessibility and for
example when we look at modules that
were specific to microclear we found
enrichment
for p1 effectors for cortical
glutamatergic neurons strong enrichment
called ehlh
nor d neuro g family factors but we were
particularly interested in this module
one the top module which
seemed to be accessible across all
neuronal cell types and has lower
accessibility and expression
in non-neuronal cell types and
surprisingly we found a strong
enrichment for
ctcf mav2d and rfx
factors in this module and it's
particularly interesting with ctcf ctcf
it's a ubiquitously
expressed dna binding protein which
well-described functioning
as an insulator and chromatin
organization involves
protein and it was just recently shown
that it can also
be involved in neurogenesis by
regulating the protocaterine
locus but our data here actually show
that it's
involved in a much higher variety and
many more biological processes
which are relevant to the neurons
including axon gynecons
synaptic transmission and so forth
and i'm just showing you here one
example qi lgi one which is
involved in in regulating priesthood
synaptic transmission and in this locus
we found a distal element
with ctcf binding site that interacted
with the promoter of lgi1
in a specific way in um in
neuronal cell types but was not
accessible in the non-neuronal cell
types and
this accessibility was also accompanied
by a low dna methylation value
further strengthening the notion that
this actually um fixed regulatory
element
driving expression for lgi1
and we have also set up a web portal for
exploration of the data so
uh please feel free to to check it out
and with that i would like to sum up by
um
by concluding that we have generated i
think a very
um large community resource of 800 000
nuclear
chromatin accessibility profiles which
corresponded roughly to 160 subtypes
we've uh generated a resist regulatory
element
list of 490 000 elements
subset of these 85 000 could be linked
to
roughly 10 000 included with target
chains and finally we indicate a roll of
rfx ctcf factors and regulating
pan neuronal enhancers and regulating a
broad spectrum of neuronal processes and
with that i would like to thank
our collaborators and especially uh
margarita berenslab
and margarita baron and yasinta lucero
for
preparing making the dissections and
preparing the nuclei
xiaomangu and xin xinwang for
generation of the data and dr yan li for
data analysis and with that i would like
to close and hand over to shuchu chang
from the stock institute
thank you for the short introduction
from sebastian we are also interested in
epigenetic diversity in the neurons
and specifically we study the
methylation
in the mouse brain using single nucleus
maximum sequencing that we developed in
the lab
in addition we want to understand this
epigenetic signature in the context of
other features of the neurons such as
the neuronal connectivity
to study this i developed a method
called epiretrosic
that combines both the ventral grade
tracing with single nucleus methylene
sequences
so first we want to generate a
comprehensive map of the dna methylation
profile in the mouth spring
we use single nucleus maximum sequencing
and acid more than 110 thousand
cells from 45 different brain regions
including part of isocortex
olfactory area hippocampus and cerebral
nuclei
those are the same samples that were
used for the single nucleus ataxic data
that i can just talk about so we have
very nice matching data set
with this data set we we performed
three-level
inter iterative clustering analysis
and uh predicted 161
subtypes as layout here as you can see
we see this really diverse
methylation profiles across different
cell types
similar to the diversity review by the
single sound rna study and apexic study
which we are most excited about this
data set
is that the ability to directly predict
enhancers
from this data set so we actually
combine both our
methylation data and the single cell
atex data from fingering slab
and predicted 1.6 enhancer-like
regulatory elements
here i'm showing on the right some
examples of enhancers predicted around
this gene bcl-1 bcl11b
goes upstream and downstream so this
gene is specifically hypo
isolated in c1 indicating an active
state
and the enhancers predicted around this
gene are also hypomethylated in c1
indicating the active state of the
enhancer element
so could this be a case of active
enhancer regulating this active
transcription of the gene in a very
say one specific fashion to further
analyze this we use the measure called
snm3c6 a measure developed in the lab
to combine the chromatin conformation
capture and begin methylation sequencing
using this method in hippocampus we
virtualize the promoting contact space
in different hippocampus cell tags
as you can see on the left each cell
type has a unique
chromatin conformation signature
one of the examples sterilized on the
right and highlighted in blue
so this chromatin loop interacting or
interaction between two chromatin
regions
is specific in c1 but not present in dg
in this look uh the interacting partners
are about 500 kb apart
on one end it contains a promoter region
of a specific proxy one
transcript and the promoter region's
hypomasilitis we've grown
a taxi signal in c1 on the other end
interacting enhancers are also
hypomethylated
and uh with strong apexic signal also in
c1
so this is a nice example of active
enhancer
interacting with promoter in a cell type
specific fashion
and this is only one example of almost
14 000
c1 enhancers that are specifically
associated with a1 specific
commenting group so now we have a
comprehensive map
of the regulatory landscape in the mouth
spring neurons
what we want to understand further is
how does epigenetic diversity correlate
with the neuronal
connectivity in our study we use abby
retrofig
and label the projection neurons with
jfp by injecting
av retro in one of the 10 projection
targets
and from each of the injection we
dissected out up to eight cortical
sources
from each dissection we isolate the
pip labeled projection neurons using
flow cytometry and analyze them using
single nucleus maximum sequencing
at the end we gather data from almost 12
000
projection neurons and for each of them
we have three information
their location the source where they
project to the target
and their methylation profile using all
the information together
we can start to understand how different
factors contribute to the
dms elation variation between neurons
in this case both the source region the
cell body location and the projection
target
contribute to the methylation variation
in projection neurons
but to different degrees to take a
closer look at this we focus
on the layer 5et neurons and further
analyze the heterogeneity within layer
5et neurons
and identified 15 subclasses
comparing the subclasses to where the
neuron locates
the source it's clear to us that the
source alone does
not explain the heterogeneity for
example for the mop
neurons the red the red neurons
on the left they locate in multiple
subclasses
suggesting other factors are in play
defining the heterogeneity
so whether that could be the projection
target
to investigate that we further take all
the
mop neurons identified subclasses within
ammo
neurons and then overlay that
information with the projection target
deformation of neurons
so repeating this analysis for all the
neurons from other source regions to
different projection targets
we have this comprehensive map that from
which we can
right away see something really
interesting for example
for the modular projecting neurons from
mot
or ssp we can see on the
corner those modular projecting neurons
are clearly enriched in specific
subclasters in mlp or ssd this suggests
that
this specific sub cluster emo prssp
a defining feature is modular projection
and the modular projecting neurons have
been synced
in methylation programs from other layer
type et neurons
in addition we have a very interesting
observation
that some of the neurons projecting to
primary zero cortex from aca
orisp are code clustered with the layer
518 era
so this is really interesting as to
interesting to us that it supports
there could be a rare population of
their 518 neurons
that also project to cortical targets
so we verify the existence of those
neurons
by labeling the cell body of rsp neurons
that project to primary zero cortex
therefore we can examine the axonal
projections
and indeed we see the clear external
projection signals
in thalamus superior superior
folliculars and pumps
supporting that those neurons are indeed
simultaneously projecting to et
target and primary neurocortex so this
is the one nice example of the power of
our data
and the apparatus that not only can we
study epigenetic
signatures of different distinct
projection neurons
we can also identify interesting real
population
so with that i'd like to thank every
member of our
really fantastic sambar group led by joe
and ed
so our next speaker is iran makamol from
usa
he'll be talking about the joint
analysis of epigenetic data and
transform
transcriptomic data
okay well thank you for the opportunity
to to present our work here and thanks
to the
organizers of this really fascinating
symposium um
i'm excited to share with you the work
of the of a really
large collaboration this has been a
collaborative effort of a working group
as part of the biccn to investigate
joint epigenomic and transcriptomic
analyses of the
of the data sets specifically for
focusing on the
most primary motor cortex
so as you've seen from the the previous
speakers
um the biccn is really making amazing
strides towards building an annotated
parts list for the brain and you know we
we take the perspective that having this
parts list and understanding
the molecular identities and something
about the connectivity and
and other features of of the
of the cellular components of the brain
is really the first step towards
understanding function
uh but the question arises with the with
the data sets
which is how do we um arrive at some
kind of
uh validity for the
level of resolution at which we divide
the the components of the brain
um and this was really recognized in the
in the brain initiatives uh
founding documents where they identified
you know identifying cell types as the
starting point for intellectual
technical progress
just to contrast artificial neural
networks that um are
have been so successful in computation
use
in general a very limited set of cell
types and we're really interested in
understanding how the
the diversity of biological cell types
uh contributes to
to brain circuit function
so as i mentioned we focused uh as
a as a group we decided within the biccm
to focus on the primary motor cortex as
an
initial test case and we produced uh
data sets
including over six hundred thousand high
quality single cells
from a variety of technologies and
platforms so
uh we had um transcriptomic data some of
which has been
uh shown by the previous speakers
epigenomic data including
open chromatin from ataxic and dna
methylation from
s m c seek that you heard about from
juju and sebastian
previous to me and so this plot shows
the number of cells that we
have from each modality and it's i think
it's destructive to look at the
um the trade-off between the number of
cells here on the x-axis that are that
can be profiled with each modality
this is really a function of the of of
the cost of the techniques
versus the number of the amount of
information that's obtained per cell
which
scales with the number of unique
molecules um that are that are captured
and
sequenced uh and so you can see on one
end of the spectrum we have
techniques like ataxic and and um
uh 10x based rna-seq that that
profile many many cells with with fewer
reads per cell
compared with the epigenomic data from
dna methylation on the left
that shows uh much higher information
per cell for for a
more modest number of cells
so one of the first questions we asked
was what
uh what cell types do we derive when we
analyze each of these
data sets each of the modalities on
their own and so
with in terms of transcriptomic data you
can see here this is already
um a joint analysis of seven data sets
so these are seven different
transcriptome data sets and and you can
see um
the expected diversity of excitatory and
inhibitory cell types as well as
uh glial cells uh
we combine this with meta-neighbor
analysis um
this is work performed by uh jesse
gillis's lab
using their technique that that looks at
the statistical replicability
of individual cell types across data
sets so it's really a stringent test of
of how
how well a given cell type can be
predicted based on signatures that are
present in
in totally independent data sets and the
result was that over 70
transcriptomic cell types could be
reliably
replicated with with a higher
applicability score
we found similar patterns using the dna
methylation data on its own or the
attack seek data on its own
the next step was really to look into
integrating these data sets so
here you can see examples of the
signatures of
a particular gene k2a in in terms of dna
methylation dna accessibility
and gene expression and the motivation
for for integrating them is really
threefold so
first of all by by integrating at the
single level we're able to
validate the predicted cell types across
across these really independent
biological features
the integrated dataset also gives us
molecular signatures of brain cell types
across
the modalities and you know ultimately
we're interested in in understanding
mechanisms of gene regulation and
persistent cell type identity
and that really requires comparing at a
single cell level the
the epigenetic and transcriptomic
regulation
so we treated this problem as a missing
data problem where
we're in uh for each individual cell
that we
profiled we have a one set of features
for example gene expression but we're
missing information about the
the complementary features such as dna
methylation and chromatin accessibility
um we took two different
approaches to filling in these missing
data
a single cell fusion developed in my lab
and liger that you heard about earlier
from
evan mccosker and josh welch
and in both cases used the
gene body signatures of regulation so
gene body chromatin accessibility or
gene body dna methylation
as well as the the gene expression level
estimated from the rna-seq data
as a common ground for integrating the
the cell types we're able to
to link cells across data sets by using
these gene body signatures
and that following the integration we
can then go back and look at
intergenic distal elements such as
enhancers
that were not used directly for the
integration
so the joint analysis identified over 50
cell types we actually came up with 56
cell types using both single cell fusion
and and liger
um you can see that the uh the cell
types integrate very well by
across all of the modalities um and just
again to emphasize these this
includes both transcriptomic and
epigenomic information so it's really
um it was very encouraging to see this
uh high level of integration
moreover the the cell types that were
derived from the
the integrated data were highly
consistent with those that came up
came from the rna-seq analysis on its
own
um the and then the number of
cells from each modality was also
consistent
across cell types
one really i think striking way of
um visualizing the the consistency of
these data sets is to look at
particular genes so for example this
gene tshc2 uh
has a very clear signature of
gene expression as well as open
chromatin and low dna methylation
in the same group of cell types and so
here
these heat maps show similar uh plots
for
for i think 30 or so marker genes
and you can see really a high level of
conservation across the cell type
again once we have the integrated cell
types we could then
create browser views where where we look
at
the the at the level of individual cell
types the dna methylation
open chromatin and gene expression
not just at gene bodies but also in uh
distal elements
so i just want to advertise that this is
a resource that's available
um either we actually have multiple
resources that have been shared in in
our by archive preprint including this
genome browser
as well as um as well as
other tools for analyzing individual
cells
okay so how can we address this question
of of validating the
the cell types and the resolution of
cell type
uh well at one level we we saw that
at a very coarse grained level of cell
types we have very consistent signatures
of the cell types across all of the
modalities
zooming into the just the mge derived
gabaergic neurons
we see that subtypes individual
subclasses of parvalbumin
or sst cells also have very consistent
signatures across
each of the modalities that were
included in this joint dataset
the meta-neighbor analysis also could be
refined to the level of individual
cell types and so this plot is showing
the area under the roc curve
derived from meta neighbor which again
the the
red blocks along the diagonal illustrate
that we have very strong
very high replicability of cell types
across
each of the modalities and this is again
this is uh focusing on specifically on
the transcriptomic data set
we went on to develop a couple of
different ways of looking at a
cross-validated measure of the of the
quality of the of the clustering
and so to do this we split both the
genomic features
uh by dividing the chromosomes into uh
into two
two sets training and testing as well as
dividing cells into training and testing
sets and by doing this we could derive a
cross-validated
measure of the mean squared error of our
cluster predictions
and we could do this as a function of
the the resolution of the cluster so by
varying a resolution parameter we could
find a u-shaped curve that shows the
minimum mean squared error
at a at a resolution of around 60 to 100
cell types in this case for the
smartseek rna-seq dataset
we performed this this same
cross-validation analysis across each of
the
each of the eight data sets
and derived the the optimal number of
clusters
a more stringent type of uh cross
validation was performed across
data sets where we actually again
divided the the gene sets into training
and testing
and then performed the the integration
analysis using just uh
training data um and then use that to
derive
an optimal number of clusters and we we
did this also as a function of the
number of cells so by down sampling the
the data sets we could
look at how the number of clusters that
we're able to
to estimate scales with the size of the
data set
interestingly we found that as we
as the size of the data sets approaches
several tens of thousands or more we we
do see some signs of
saturation of the number of cross
validated clusters across
data sets
um so just to acknowledge the folks who
contributed to this
work this was really as i mentioned a
large collaboration of over 80
collaborators uh the lead authors on the
on the joint analysis were um vision
yahoo hanching liu
hung she and stefan fisher um
and conquising at the allen institute
and i were the the leaders of the
uh of the overall working group um and
we just want to thank
uh the funders uh in the brain
initiative as well as um all of our
collaborators within semba the
epigenomic consortium
and with that i'd like to go ahead and
turn it over to basilica tacit from the
allen institute
thank you very much uh for organizing
this
meeting and for inviting me to give a
talk uh today i will talk about the
viral genetic tools for targeting mouth
and primate
uh brain cell types and i would really
like to start with
acknowledging that i'm very fortunate to
be part of the allen institute
where teen science is encouraged for it
and what i will present today
is the result of efforts of federal
scientific and support
as well as superb leadership within the
celtics program by the allen
leaders hong kong zhang and edwin
i would also like to highlight several
colleagues who have played the major
role in this project
lucas greybach and tanya they go from
mouse genetic tools team
and john mitch boss lobby and jonathan
tink who lead the human genetic tools
and the newly formed
cns gene therapy team we have also
collaborated with teams outside the
allen
and have received generous support from
the brain initiative
we have had a long history of
building and sharing genetic tools with
the science community
this effort at the allen was spearheaded
by hungary zhang and is now led by tane
daego and me
uh all alan mice go to jax
where they're broadly distributed to the
scientific community and what i would
like to highlight in today's talk
is that there is a game-changing
approach in genetic tools that relies
not on germline transgenesis
which will certainly continue to be
important but
on adeno-associated virus vectors that
enable cell class
or cell type specific expression in the
mouse brain
the work i will highlight today was
published in by archive in 2019
and we updated the two publications uh
this year
it is currently in revision these are
greybuck and they go at all and michelle
and i will be able to provide only
highlights today but for more details
please
refer to those to pre-print
so how did this change in the way we
design and build
genetic tools come to be it was really
enabled
by new single cell genomic profiling
technologies that allow us to measure
thousands of genetic features in a cell
transcript or open chromatin sites and
then use those features to
systematically classify cells
this classification not only provides
hierarchical relationships of cells
from broad categories like classes to
uh finer like subclasses and types
but it also reveals specific genes many
of them previously not known as marker
genes
as well as the putative regulatory
elements in the case of a taxi
that can be used to make genetic tools
and here i'm just highlighting
some of the genes some of the markers
that are specifically expressed in
certain classes subclasses
or types
two technologies uh also reveal
cell type diversity in homology across
species here
exemplified by two taxonomies one from
mouse and the other from human cortex
and having this information really begs
the question can we make tools that work
across species
to do this because germline transmission
is either not
ethically or practically feasible in
many organisms besides mass we focused
our
effort on finding putative regulatory
elements that could be isolated from the
genome
cloned into adeno-associated virus
vectors
and delivered to animals without
germline transmission to define these
elements we use single-cell tactic
uh the two data sets are described in
the two preprints
one from mouse visual cortex and the
other from human middle temporal gyrus
without going into details i would like
to highlight that differential chromatin
accessibility can be used to define cell
clusters
mostly at the level of subclass we can
correlate these data with single cell
transcriptomics
and then we can identify
punitive regulatory elements that are
specific to certain ataxi clusters
then we can
take these differentially accessible
regions
some that are present in one class or
one type versus all others and use them
as putative enhancers to build new
genetic tools
and our workflow is on the left
so what we do is we first prioritize the
cell subcluster type
we want to focus on then we find genomic
regions that are specifically accessible
and sometimes we also look at
proximity of marker genes as a
conservation we clone these into
uh recombinant associated virus genomes
um these either drive it directly
fluorophores or
exogenous recombinated then we produce
and screen these viruses and there is
really a variety of clinic screening
platforms we
employ but many of them rely initially
on
the mouse and then for the most
promising candidates we actually test
them across species using either
individual
or in vitro approaches
i will be able to highlight just a
couple of
tools the first one i would like to
highlight
focused on layer 5 subcortically
projecting neurons also known as layer 5
pyramidal tract
or extra talent cephalic neurons we
selected a number of putative enhancers
and build genetic tools that drive
either directly a fluorophore or
recombinant
we observed a pretty remarkable
specificity
with the direct fluorophore and uh
recombinates roughly about 90 percent of
the cells labeled world layer 5
pt cells um
i would also like to highlight that the
completeness of labeling
depends on the route of the
administration of the
uh of the reagent in this particular
case in retro-orbital delivery mice
the completeness is relatively low only
about 30 percent
uh however it can be improved with
direct stereotactic injection as i will
highlight on the next slide
we're also able to examine the
expression of these enhancer viruses
throughout the whole brain using two
photon tomography with tissue side
and have also shown that some of these
tools can work in human brain slices
to label equivalent cell subclass
in the next slide um i will highlight
beauty i will highlight tools
built by focusing on the parvobumin
interneuron subclass
in this case um
we tested three different i'm just
highlighting the three different
enhancers that were tested by
human genetic tools um
in fact this particular experiment was
performed by performing stereotactic
injections in the macaque brain um
three different viruses were tested and
subsequently essay for specificity and
completeness of labeling of immunities
to chemistry
and these three different constructs
containing three different enhancers
really displayed excellent specificity
uh at 86 to 95 percent and
good to quite excellent completeness at
63
to 92 percent
i would also like to mention that these
tools in mice
are compatible with standard mouse uh
trenching
um and in this particular case we'll
build a new tool
that allows uh genetically different
populations of cells to be labeled in a
single animal
so if you deliver three different
enhancers cloned into three different
viruses
into this new tool ai-213
delivered uh through retro-orbital
injections
we can observe in the same piece of
tissue
two different layer five excitatory
neurons
excitatory subclasses of neurons and
disperse throughout the cortex
inhibitory neurons but these tools are
also compatible with
existing tools
and novel tools like the one highlighted
here
um i will briefly just highlight that we
have now
uh together as a team effort at the
allen
um been able to cover
uh truly most major classes of neurons
so on the right i'm showing this part of
the
mouse cortical taxonomy
um the coverage by
viruses that we have produced at the
allen in blue are the ones validated by
ann fisher's single cell rna-seq by
specificity and in gray are the ones
labeled or
validated by just preliminary
observation of cell location apology and
i'm happy to report that we have
coverage of all major classes of neurons
as well as some non-neuronal classes and
are making inroads
to covering finer divisions in the
taxonomy like specific types of parallel
human cells for example
where do we go from here i would be
really excited
to collaborate across bicc and to
integrate data sets and analysis and
therefore expand this approach to other
extracortical brain areas
then we would in a coordinated fashion
proceed to build
and screen aav tools and characterize
the most promising one in multiple
platforms of species
and ultimately what i hope to provide we
will provide to the community are
publicly available data
reagents and recipes for targeting cell
classes and subclasses
in the mouse and primary brain take
transgene x and virus y
to be able to label cell type c
and with this uh i would like to
complete this session i would like to
thank our founder paul allen for his
vision encouragement and support
thank you for your attention and i would
like to open the session for questions
okay i'd like to thank you uh all the
speakers
and now the podium is open for
submitting
questions so for the audience who want
to submit
questions please click ask a question
button and send you the question
in so the first question
molecular or mixed data may reflect some
access
of biological identity such as
developmental specification
based on genetically based patterning
we know neurons differ with respect to
many observable
phenotypic features including morphology
location connectivity
electrophysiological properties
besides genetic makeup and
transcriptomic characteristics
moreover neurons are highly influenced
by a large number of
interacting cells can transcriptomic
and epigenomic profiles of brain cells
become a surrogate and the sufficient
definition
of the cell types
so maybe start with evan
yeah sure this is a great question it's
one that i think
a lot of us here on the panel think a
lot about um
i i like to think of this question i
mean i think
the answer is um no not until we really
understand the relationship
between the transcriptomic features and
these other phenotypic features
and i think the best analogy that i've
gotten to this problem
is uh is is in from human genetics
so in human genetics um uh
you know you can imagine clustering
people based on their
their overall uh you know genotype right
and
uh that genotype is going to be most
heavily influenced by ancestry and
things like that
but if you really wanted to understand
all the features of a person it would be
impossible to use those clusters
to do that so for example uh lactose
intolerance right which is a phenotype
that
we care some people care a lot about um
that
that phenotype is driven by you know one
or just a couple genes
and so uh you would only really be able
to relate that to the genome if you
understood the relationship between that
phenotype and that genotype
just clustering based on the overall uh
you know features is not going to give
you that insight because people are not
going to there's so many other
influences besides
that one um you know lactose influence
that's affecting the genotype and so
you're only going to get the overall
broad brush strokes
so it's really about next era is to
really find
relationships between um these other
features that we know are so important
with the transcriptomic features and i
think that's what you've seen in many of
these presentations today
but silke you also mentioned you might
want to answer this too
yeah no i i completely agree and i think
this is really a wonderful uh analogy
i just want to say that um yeah beyond
um there are a couple of things that we
need to take into account first the
measurements
and the quality of measurements of
different modalities really differs
therefore we may sometimes conclude
there is no
let's say difference in one modality or
that there is in another but actually
maybe
we're able to measure more features with
higher accuracy
something that appears either as a no
difference or as a continuum
may in fact become discrete in that
modality that maybe we couldn't measure
very well
and the second thing is i completely
agree with you understanding
relationships
really matters because when you measure
everything
um some fine relationships may be
some relationships that depend on very
few features may be hidden
so okay thank you
can i maybe jump and comment on this
question too because i think it's a
great question
okay come on is that okay this is a
wrong book um i completely agree with
what evan and basilica said and you know
we really need to understand
how these things hang together um at the
same time i think one of the
lessons one of the remarkable things to
me
of of this field is is how um
how correlated many of the phenotypes of
cells are
and so um you know as juju showed for
example in her talk there
they didn't necessarily have to be a
transcriptomic or a
dna methylation signature of the
connectivity pattern of neurons
um but it turns out that there is and we
can
uh infer certain aspects of the
projection pattern of
cortical projection neurons from the dna
methylation and i think we're still at
the very early days of understanding all
of those relationships
but i think our experience with the data
so far i would say gives hope that
there are going to be very robust
signatures that are correlated across
many of these
modalities that will allow us to to use
the molecular signatures as kind of a
defining
core classification
but i but you know that's a hypothesis
that i think we're all testing
hi this is juju i just want to quickly
chime in
that i agree completely with iran that
we are just scratching the surface
of our relationship from our data i
think it
will be very exciting to see with more
data in the future and more
modalities uh what kind of connections
our relationships between those
different features
and also i think with the epigenetic
data we have
we also have the hope to understand the
regulation
behind underlying those connections that
for example enhancers from the talk you
heard about
how whether we can use enhancers to
really label certain cell types with
certain specific properties and
further study them
okay the next related question is really
about
the consistency of the molecular
characterization so
so this is a two lungs
talk the the many effort study indicates
that
mouse primary motor cortex contains over
55
neuronal cell types that are highly
replicable across molecular analysis
methods
however computational data integration
of single cell and the single nucleus
rna-seq data alone
can enable clustering and identification
of
90 neuronal types in the same region
could you please clarify what this
difference in the number of
neuronal types is due to the relatively
low number of
cells sampled in epigenomic
profiling modalities or some
due to some different statistical
criteria used for clustering
yes thank you for the question it's it's
um you know this
this question was really the reason that
we wanted to so
carefully look at um objective
measures of cross-validation of the cell
types
uh to be able to address this question
of what's the right level of resolution
you know we talk a lot about lumpers and
splitters
um and two two different groups or two
different scientists can look at the
same data set
and come to different conclusions about
what the
right grouping of cell types may be um
so i would say actually the the um
the results of our analysis were quite
consistent so actually if you look at
the number of replicable
clusters that we found for example using
meta-neighbor in the rna-seq data was
was somewhere around 70.
um and the
55 neuronal cells that you're referring
to from the epigenomic data that's
actually from
a joint analysis of the uh epigenomic
and transcriptomic data
um which actually included all of the
cells so over 600 000 and so so so that
that certainly wasn't limited by the
number of cell
samples um but one thing i do want to
emphasize is that
you know we report kind of the the
minimum mean squared error uh the point
at which the
the clustering that has the minimum v
squared error but there was really a
range
of cluster resolution that was
compatible with the data
um and which had roughly similar kind of
agreement with the data and so i think
what that
tells us is that
there's not at least these data don't
clearly define
whether there are exactly 50 55 cell
types or 56
or 65 there's a range and you know that
range
um spans you know
from something like 50 to 100 cell types
um you know it's far more than i think
many of us would have anticipated that
you know a few years ago um but it's
it's not a single number and so i think
um our challenge is now to describe what
those cell types are
and how do they relate to each other
going forward
any other speakers
this sebastian um i'm i'm also thinking
that
that that the cell cluster the cell
number is a very difficult question from
that
point of view that some might might be
different based on
a transcriptome others might be
different based on epigenomic data so i
think
at this point it's really hard to
understand until we have really
phenotypic uh electric circuit data to
really understand what are the distinct
cell types even doing
or are these kind of like molecular uh
phenotypes that we don't understand
fully
in yeah
okay so i received several specific
questions
and one is for sebastian from dr gregory
horowitz at the university of washington
what fraction of putative enhancers were
associated with the nearest
gene on the linear genome
yeah thank you for that question we have
not looked into
into the fraction of the nearest gene i
would presume it's somewhere around like
50
but we haven't looked in that particular
data set
so the next questions for basilica
are from dr koichi hashikawa
at the university of washington is the
viral approaches to target cell types
can you drive
the expression of pre or flip
under the enhancer elements while
ensuring specificity
sorry i'm not sure i under uh
there is also i already answered how to
control the specificity i think it was
also by koichi hashikawa is that
that sort of an equivalent question how
to control specificity with viruses
given that there are so many
aspects that you have to control
uh young do you think that's the same
question
yeah so uh he thinks
the small leak of gree and uh
may potentially reduce the specifically
specifically
dramatically yes so
i think viruses though
more convenient more easily shareable
more portable
yes there are many challenges one is
tighter
with tighter things will vary with
method of delivery
the specificity and completeness will
vary um
whether it's a recombinant or it's a
direct support for
again the specificity and completeness
will vary so i think
in order for viruses to really be
reliably used
what we have to provide recipes
you know virus this exact virus with
this titer
delivered through this method at this
dose gives this particular
um this particular specificity
um yes i think with transgenes is easier
especially if it's a direct flora for
transgene i mean there may be some
differences with genetic background of
the level of expression or maybe
specificity but very minor here
it's much bigger so i think um that's
what we have to do
we have to test provide recipes
for people to be able to use in the
field and with recombinases we have
indeed noticed that some recombinases
do decrease specifically like cree but
if you
take cree that is not as
active actually it approaches a
very good specificity of flip so we've
done some
fantastic
okay i have a one general question from
uh dr cenierski at salk institute
what was the rationale for
focusing on the motor cortex what is
consistency in cell classes and
subclasses
across all the groups studying cell
identity
so i might want to chime being as a
program
director of this brain initiative cell
senses network and so
in my introduction slides we currently
have
more than 20 projects in this large
consortium and each project
is going to generate a different set of
cell census data as you heard today
so we actually selected molecular
characterization groups to report as
we have already collected a large amount
of data
and more than 10 million single cell
omics data already
released to the public and at the same
time
we have another major group
characterizing cell
features uh you know from the angle of
anatomical and the imaging
approaches and so these
methods the throughput is relatively
uh low and so the data generation
is a bit uh
at this moment is a bit lagging behind
but
but there are a lot of interesting uh
data already
uh generated and will be um reported
soon as well
and the focus on the motor cortex is
because
this is a relatively well-known region
and you know contains about 2 million
cells in
mouse brain and so we want to start
this focused region
and so we can compare different
technologies and protocols so that the
data generated would be
better integrated together and so
especially you know when all
many technologies are relatively new and
so
the standards need to be developed
during this
data generation process so that's a
major reason that rationale
and any other panelists want to chime in
on that
this is yeah this is trig but i
just wanted to say briefly um i think i
mentioned in my talk but it also was
very fortuitous
for a comparative analysis because this
is a
functionally conserved area and was also
identifiable in all species with with
some
high confidence so that's the only other
thing i wanted to add
yeah and this this is iran um just to
add to i think young and trigva
mentioned the main
uh kind of motivations for choosing mlp
in addition you know it's an interesting
part of cortex that has you know shares
most of the kind of federal architecture
with
with other cortical regions in terms of
the layers um
and the cell types but it also has some
differences in terms of being in a
granular
cortex and there were some open
questions about you know the
status of layer 4 for example that we
were able to address
with some new data so i think that made
it interesting for us as well
so here's another question uh so one
hypothesis that the neuronal
connectivity
functional properties and disease states
may be encoded by a cellular
transcriptome and the epigenome do you
have data suggest that other
observable phenotypic features may
indeed be inferred
by the analysis of single cell ombx data
and by
multimodal assays and this may be
also related to another question for
jujutsung
about et neurons
by sue cluster at nmh
uh thank you for the questions so yeah i
think from our data
we can clearly see that using the at
least the demethylation
um in many cases we could build a
prediction model to infer uh the
projection targets of the neuron
based on their the location of the
neuron
and i want to highlight that this
prediction
really varies in different situations
for some of the projections for example
the medulla example i
showed um it's it's really quite
clear-cut
but for some other projections for
example the pump
versus the pure colliculus that
difference really depending on
which which brain region which cortical
region we are looking at
i think uh our i think we look into that
that really comes from
many of the neurons have zero projection
where our study only looked at one
single projection target
so uh i think earlier we talked about
this i think it's like there's a lot
more to be learned
i think there's we're really just
starting to see how much information is
encoded
um in the epigenome our transcriptome
and fold the out layer 5et neurons that
project to
cortical targets so in this case we look
at a zero cortex projection
and in anterior singulate aca
we analyzed more than a thousand neurons
and
about 30 of them are projected to sorry
modern thousand layer fat et neurons
more than 30 projected to zero cortex
so about three percent um in rsp the
percentage would be higher about ten
percent so out of
about five hundred cells we um their et5
et cells we saw
about 50 neurons that project to zero
cortex
thanks
young i think there was also a part of
that question about
if i understood correctly about whether
we
[Music]
saw evidence of cell state differences
or or
activity dependence of of the
um either epigenomic transcriptomic
elements and just to address that i mean
i think overall the bicc has really been
focused on
um you know characterizing the landscape
of um
stable cell type identities and so we've
been very careful to focus on you know
sampling um animals in uniform
conditions um and haven't focused on
activity dependence but i think
uh having a baseline knowledge of the of
the
landscape of all of the the cell types
uh and
will allow us going forward to look to
look at that i think
we do expect to find for example
activity regulated
differences in enhancer activity um and
gene expression
but that isn't something that we've
directly looked at i don't know if
others want to comment on that as well
well this is trig but i just wanted to
comment actually on the original
question of
sort of linking omics profiles to other
cellular features
and i mean i think as you just said
we're we're just now collecting the data
to start
to asking these questions about creating
predictive models but
um i just wanted to highlight too that
the comparative analysis
defining these uh homologous types
across species actually is a predictive
model of sorts
in that for example chandelier cells
right we we already knew that the
morphologies looked quite similar across
species but we went into this with an
unbiased approach and identified that as
sort of a one-to-one match
and so in fact could have predicted the
the morphology of chandelier cells in
primates
based on the morphology and mouse and of
course there'll be species
specializations over
over evolution but at least it gives a
starting point for
making predictions of phenotypes predict
particularly for phenotypes that can't
easily or
really at all be measured in for example
human brain such as long-range
projections
so we have also homologous types for
for example the corticospinal neurons
and that would be very difficult if not
impossible to
to sort of really verify um in a human
brain so i think it
that's just another use of the the
comparative approach
yeah and i i know we are um close to out
of town time but just
um jumping on trigva and
aaron's last comments one thing that
this next phase is particularly poised
to do is really think about
inter-individual variability and and
thinking about
more diverse genomic and genetic
backgrounds um
but the the corollary of that is is
really getting a handle on the
environmental influence on
transcriptomes so one thing that we have
observed is that
we see high inter-individual variability
across
human samples but much less so amongst
um
laboratory reared non-human primates
which are
um just as genetically diverse and so
that really
puts an emphasis on understanding how
much
environmental variability we might need
to face when we move to
to either wild type or or human samples
so here's a probably a quick question to
the panel members
are your is your study already published
maybe starting with evan
oh um ours is on bioarchive i think a
lot of the studies are part of our
um you know the the the recent
compendium of biccn papers and and
we're all quite committed to releasing
them on bioarchive in advance
yeah so i just want to mention uh
the most
presentations discussed today
if not published in by archive and will
be
uh submitted to nature or by icon soon
and so this is uh is the ongoing effort
right now
uh for the brain initiative sentence
network
investigators to publish their results
and also try to integrate data together
moving forward so with that
i think our time is almost up and i want
to just ask
um each speakers if they have any
uh quick one sentence summary
or uh about their work or some future
direction they want to take
for silicon maybe i was thinking is
somebody going to speak before me no
okay i um
i'm really really excited about what we
were able to do with nbaccm it's really
amazing
working together generating all these
data and then analyzing them together to
find
common uh sort of common rules
uh and common types across different
modalities
again mentioning that you know different
data
do not always give the same answer but
there is a really
an amazing agreement so my hope is
really that we can leverage
these data to build genetic tools for me
this would be i think transformative for
the
for the whole neuroscience field and not
only mouse but also across species
i've just received a couple of emails
about rat
primate uh i think that would be really
a game changer in non-genetic
animals and sorry that was more than one
sentence
just to chime in on that this this is
trig but um i just wanted to say as
we're studying this sort of regulatory
genome
and understanding and identifying for
example viral enhancers i think we have
an opportunity to really study
cell type evolution and principles of
that as we understand that regulatory
logic across species
and i also think this sort of again
looking
looking at different species and
particularly model organisms can really
maybe guide
good selection of those model organisms
for for the community at large
so i look forward to yeah future future
coordination of
focusing on individual brain regions and
and sort of like the collaborative
analysis effort i think was really
fruitful
all right i'll shine in our you know our
relevant study i think
really uh surprised us
that um that novel cell types can be
discovered
um even in the modern era in a structure
that's been so heavily studied
i think the uh the sort of relatively
untouched structures of the hindbrain
the midbrain
um and and other you know uh sub
subcortical structures i think are going
to
uh provide the most immediate and
obvious
uh use to the neuroscience community as
we
just discover uh very basic principles
of tissue structure that we didn't know
before
so this is around uh you know i think my
one sentence would be
you know that some people sometimes ask
the question is it too many cell types
there was a paper with that title by
chuck stevens from 20 years ago that
they came across
and i think what this has show this this
collaboration
has has shown me is that the data really
insists to us that there are you know a
very
um a broad diversity of uh
types in the brain and i think the next
challenge for us is to understand
uh why and what what they're doing and
also how they arise in development so i
think we have
some of the data that can can help us to
understand them from that perspective as
well
uh this is juju i just want to echo
everything it's already said but
i think from our study it's really
just amazing to us to see how how
complicated the whole system is
all the different factors could
contribute to
um basic our project to the variation we
see in the dna methylation or other
modalities i think it's really like
we've already said a lot like really
important to connect all the different
modalities and also
the enhancer identification and
validation
functional study is definitely a um a
future direction we are very interested
in
actively pursuing
anything to add sebastian alexander
yeah and just a another synthetic
synthesis of where they've been said but
um what we've come to appreciate is is
measuring more than one species more
than one
region certainly gave us insights that
we would not otherwise have
have had both in the ways that um cell
types evolve and also how they might
develop differently in different genetic
contexts
um so development i think is a clear new
path that is that
the iccn is already invested in and that
could lead to real insights into how
some of these
some of these novelties or unexpected uh
cell types or
states come to me
and this is sebastian so what i feel
like
is it really shows and what really
excites me is kind of like to
have this integrated approach between
all the molecular modalities and the
phenotype and the anatomy and
really trying to understand and i think
now we might be on the verge to be able
to understand how
gene regulation and enhancer element can
kind of like contribute
and where is it encoded in the genome
this diversity so i'm
really excited about what will come out
of this comprehensive analysis that we
will conduct in the future
okay with that i want to wrap up this
student
by thanking again all simple speakers
and the audience as well
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thanks